Who's to blame?
An exiled former
Russian lawmaker
linked with militant groups
in Russia tells CNN
that he does
not think it is
Ukraine and said it is Russian Partizans
whom he believes are behind the alleged
drone attack over the Kremlin.
Overnight video reviewed
by CNN
seems to show drones
flying over the heavily
fortified building
in Russia's capital of Moscow.
Russian officials
claim Ukraine
was trying to assassinate President
Vladimir Putin,
though
Putin, of course, was
not there at the time.
And Ukraine strongly denies
any involvement.
And there doesn't seem to be any evidence
Ukraine was involved.
Nick Paton
Walsh is in Ukraine
tonight where the brutal war rages on
and at least 21
people, 21
people were killed in the latest round
of Russian attacks.
It's on
the edges of imagination,
but the Kremlin insists it's real.
An apparent drone flies into the Kremlin
and detonate
right on its dome,
captured on many cameras.
A truly seismic allegation.
Russia saying Ukraine
sent two drones to kill President
Vladimir Putin,
but he wasn't home as the smoke rose.
These videos played out globally.
Unverified.
And the only slim
evidence of the Kremlin's claim
it is a moment that carries great risk
for the Kremlin
ahead of an annual Victory Day parade
there just next week. It's embarrassing.
They have claimed such
a breach of security happened
and there will be calls
for their battered military
to find a way to escalate.
Now they have Ukrainian
President Zelensky
on a visit to Finland today
issued a flat denial.
We don't attack
Putin or Moscow.
We fly too on on our territory.
And we are defending our villages
and cities.
We don't have,
you know, enough weapons for these.
The US also not convinced
I would take anything
coming out of the Kremlin
with a very large shaker of salt.
But fear of Russian reprisals
rising again in Ukraine,
where bombings already
definitely do happen every day and night.
Over a dozen dead
this day in a recently liberated house on
a railway station shelled
and a supermarket midmorning.
Tension mounting here
ahead of an expected
Ukrainian counteroffensive.
So from Friday,
there is a 58 hour curfew.
Nobody coming out of their homes
in that area
on night was shaken by sirens and blasts
Here is where they hit homes.
The first missile landing outside
and leaving
enough time
for families to jump into the bath
or shelter their children
before the second left this hole.
But over
at the process,
you know,
we were in such stress, Lyudmila says.
But it was only when people asked us
if we were okay
that we realized we were alive.
Like in the Kremlin.
Nobody killed or injured here either,
but lives destroyed
and no doubt who was behind it
Now, Jake,
there are two ways of looking at this.
One, this is an extraordinary lapse
of security
around the Kremlin,
one that is deeply embarrassing
to Vladimir Putin himself and suggests
that his grip on that tight
security apparatus around him
and around
Russia may be slipping or eroding
And the second is that
this is an elaborate
and we've seen it before complex,
what you call a false flag
operation designed
by Russia
to potentially
falsely provide
a pretext for something else.
That is what people are most concerned
about here in Ukraine.
They've seen this
in Russia's history in the past.
They claim they've been attacked
in a new unprecedented way,
and they use that
to justify some new horror.
Now, many look to
what's not been used so far in Russia's
conventional arsenal.
Not too much, possibly larger bombers
and also Russia's nuclear weapons.
Deep fears about that.
Nothing material at this stage.
But Ukraine really concerned
as to where this leads Jake.
Nick Paton Walsh in Ukraine for us,
thank you so much.
Joining us to discuss,
the former secretary of defense
and former
CIA director and president
under President
Obama, Leon Panetta, Secretary Panetta,
Sources tell CNN that U.S.
officials
had no warning
that an attack like this was coming
and that the Ukrainians
assured them privately
they had nothing to do with it.
What's your take
Jake, this
this really does
smell like a false flag
operation on the part of the Russians.
A diversion if you will.
And if somebody was really trying
to make an effort
at an assassination attempt,
it was pretty far fetched.
I've been to the Kremlin.
The Kremlin is a fortress.
Well,
and Putin doesn't exactly take walks
around the Kremlin.
There's no Rose Garden at the Kremlin.
So this is this is clearly
an allegation that is false.
I don't think there's a lot of truth
to it.
And at most,
it probably
is one of these diversionary things
that kind of marks
the beginning of the spring offensives
that we're going to see pretty soon.
So, yeah,
that was going to be my next question.
If this is indeed a false flag.
Is this do you think
Russia trying to create
some sort of justification for further
nihilistic barbarism?
Not that they need it, really.
I mean, they've been doing it
now for more than a year anyway.
Yeah, I know.
But, you know, it clearly follows the the
the Putin playbook here, which is
to create these kinds of false diversions
in order to justify
some kind of action
that they're going to take.
I don't know what that action would be.
They're sending a lot of drones
over Ukraine.
They're sending a lot of
missiles over the Ukraine.
I don't know what additionally
the Russians could do at this point,
but that they're not doing now.
But having said that,
I think that the Ukrainians probably
are engaging
in some diversions themselves in Ukraine
to try to make sure that the Russians
don't quite know
where they're going
to show up in terms of their offensive.
And I'm sure the Russians are now doing
the same.
We're going to see a lot of that as we as
we work up to what I think
is, without question,
going to be a spring offensive,
certainly by the Ukrainians
and possibly by the Russians as well.
So Russian state media claims
that this drone was a
Ukrainian made drone
called a huge 22 attack drone
that theoretically
would have had to have flown
more than 300 miles to get to Moscow.
That's just from the
nearest Ukrainian border.
Would a drone like
that even
have the capacity to inflict major damage
on a building
so heavily fortified as the Kremlin
Well, yeah, Jake,
I've I've headed up drone operations
when I was a CIA director
If you're serious about using a drone,
the way you have to do it
is to frankly conduct
a great deal of surveillance
in order to make sure that you know,
that you're
going to hit the right target.
As far as I can see here, there wasn't
any kind of surveillance involved
There were just a couple of drones
that were up in the air.
So it doesn't strike me
that this was a serious effort
at certainly at an assassination,
which is far fetched.
Was it an operation to try to
create some kind of damage
at the Kremlin? Who knows?
I think it really smells
like the Russians
trying to set this up
as some kind of diversion
There just isn't a logical explanation
to try to use drones
to try to assassinate
Putin in the Kremlin.
That's just unbelievable.
Well, it's also just
I mean,
anyone who knows
anything about Putin knows.
Well, first of all, I mean, we
Ukrainians are fighting a war.
They're defending themselves.
Nobody
should think that they wouldn't
grab an opportunity
to inflict
harm on them in killing their children
if they could.
But the idea that they would send
a little drone to attack the outside
of the Kremlin
as a way to get Putin, when
I know
and I'm certainly not
Ukrainian intelligence,
I know that Putin's not spending
the night in the Kremlin.
No, that's
you know,
if anything, Putin just goes there
for ceremonial activities.
The place is well fortified.
Putin is right.
There's a tremendous amount of security
around him at that place.
If you're if you're even going to think
about a possible assassination,
you would look
at probably at his residences
outside of Moscow and near the lake.
He's got a residence as well.
But again,
you'd have to do some surveillance
to make sure that you've got a target
Otherwise, you know, just wasting time
and not really doing anything
that's going to be effective.
So I.
I just see this as there's
a lot of baloney that the Russians
are throwing out there
in order to kind of justify
any further action
that they're going
to take against Ukraine.
Former CIA Director
and Secretary of Defense
Leon Panetta, always good to see
you, sir. Thank you so much.
Good to be with you, Jack.